Hi! You got a second?
Okay.
You remember how when we were younger we used to run around...
...and hang out with Blue and find clues and talk to Mr. Salt...
...and freak out about the mail and do all the fun stuff...
...and then one day, I was like, "Oh hey, guess what?"
"Big news! I'm leaving."
"This is my brother Joe, he's your new best friend."
And then I got on a bus and I left, and we didn't see each other for a really long time.
Can we just talk about that?
Great.
Because I realized that that was kind of abrupt.
I just kinda got up and went to college, and that was really challenging, by the way.
But great because I got to use my mind and take a step at a time.
I mean now I literally am doing many of the things that I wanted to do.
And then look at you, and look at all you have done,...
...and all you have accomplished in all that time...
And it's just so amazing, right?
I mean, we started out with clues, and now it's what?
Student loans,...
...and jobs,...
...and families.
And some of it has been kind of hard, you know?
I know you know.
I wanted to tell you that I really couldn't have done all of that without your help.
And in fact, all the help that you helped me with when we were younger...
...is still helping me today.
Right now.
And that's super cool.
I guess I just wanted to say that after all these years I never forgot you ever.
And I'm super glad we're still friends.
Thanks for listening.
You look great, by the way.
Whatever it is you're doing, it's working.